kóvacs es el acrónimo en inglés del
fondo de acceso global para la vacuna
contra el cobre y 19 es una iniciativa
público-privada creada en 2020 a través
de la o ms ante la necesidad de que la
vacuna llegue al mayor número de
personas en todo el mundo de manera
rápida y justa bajo el lema solo estamos
a salvo cuando todos estamos a salvo su
principal meta es disponer de 2 mil
millones de dosis para finales de 2021
todos los países participantes recibirán
acceso a las vacunas de manera
proporcional a su población
independientemente de su nivel
socioeconómico
si bien presta especial atención a los
sectores de riesgo ya los países que no
podrían pagarlas a su precio de mercado
del mecanismo el objetivo del mecanismo
suministro de al menos 2 mil millones de
dosis de vacunas seguras y eficaces para
finales de 2000 21 twenty one of
governance mientras los gobiernos
invierten millones en estímulos
económicos
el mecanismo kóvacs ofrece un enorme
retorno de la inversión hay luz al final
del túnel
para conseguir el reparto equitativo
kóvacs lanzó junto a la alianza para la
vacunación un programa de financiación
para 92 países con un producto interno
bruto per cápita por debajo de los 4 mil
dólares que recibirán 2 y subvencionadas
por parte de los países participantes en
el proyecto sin embargo este enero el
director general de la omm se quejó de
la falta de compromiso de algunos países
y compañías farmacéuticas y updates pitt
aunque hablen el idioma del acceso
equitativo a algunos países y empresas
siguen dando prioridad a los acuerdos
bilaterales pasando por encima de kóvacs
haciendo subir los precios e intentando
ponerse a la cabeza de la cola esto es
un error
el anuncio del nuevo gobierno de eeuu de
unirse a esta iniciativa podría dotar al
proyecto de un nuevo impulso a nivel
internacional